قال برنامج الغذاء العالمي ان اكثر من ربع
سكان غزه استنفد امدادات الغذائيه وباتوا
يواجهون خطر الموت جوعا وحذر عارف حسين
كبير الخبراء الاقتصاديين في البرنامج من
مجاعه شامله في الاشهر السته المقبله اذا
استمر تقييد وصول المساعدات الانسانيه
وصفا الازمه بالتي لم يسبق لها
مثيل يؤكد هذا التقرير مخاوفنا انه وضع
يعاني فيه الجميع تقريبا في غزه من الجوع
اكثر من نصف مليون شخص يتضورون جوعا وهذا
يعني ان واحدا من كل اربعه اشخاص يعاني من
الجوع انهم الان يتضورون جوعا في غزه
بينما نحن
نتحدث الناس قريبون جدا جدا من تفشي
الامراض على نطاق واسع لان اجهزتهم
المناعيه اصبحت ضعيفه جدا فهم لا يحصلون
على ما يكفي من التغذيه وانا اتحدث حقا عن
الاطفال واتحدث عن النساء والرجال نتحدث
تقريبا عن جميع سكان المدنيين في
غزه لقد رايت افغانستان ورايت اليمن ورايت
كنت في جنوب السودان ورايت شمال شرق
نيجيريا وفي كل مكان تقريبا لكني لم ارى
قط شيئا بهذا النطاق كما يحدث في غزه
وبهذه السرعه ففي غضون شهرين فقط تدهورت
الاوضاع بشكل كبير جدا الى مستويات مدمره